et dans le flot des images de la guerre
une photo a retenu notre attention
aujourd'hui celle d'une petite fille
ukrainienne vous le voyez sa mère a
inscrit sur son dos le nom et le numéro
de téléphone de la famille des
informations en cas de séparation ou de
décès on estime à un million cinq cent
mille le nombre d'enfants qui ont dû
quitter l'ukraine et certains se
retrouve seul sans leurs parents bonjour
anne avril et merci de répondre à france
24 vous êtes la directrice générale de
l'unicef france plus de 500 enfants non
accompagnés aurait quitté l'ukraine donc
dès mineurs des enfants seuls cent par
an ce n'est qu'une estimation
absolument écouter on estime à plusieurs
centaines d'enfants les estime à 500
aujourd'hui mais c'est probablement un
peu plus on des mineurs encore pu
exposer ou encore plus danger que les
autres enfants aujourd'hui il ya 4
million et demi d'enfants qui ont été
forcées de quitter leurs foyers ce soit
à l'intérieur du pays fillon
notre estimation
donc on les prend en charge
immédiatement l'allèle la grosse
difficulté c'est déjà détecté les
mineurs non accompagnés alors certains
arrivent seuls mais se passer souvent
ils viennent avec des adultes qui nous
lé signal mais il peut arriver aussi que
ses enfants soient dans un flou et qu'
on puisse pas les identifier comme
mineurs non accompagnés donc le travail
avec le évidemment tous toutes les
autorités de l'immigration enfin moi
tout cas au poste frontière donc pourra
pour identifier ces enfants et les
mettre en lieu sûr et les prendre en
charge évidemment de manière à ce qu'il
ne soit pas encore plus en danger parce
qu'il yad'autres d'autres dangereux
qu'ils attendent dans les pays d'accueil
ou aux simples ukraine oui notamment je
lisais des adoptions express notamment
de la part d'une église évangélique
américaine là on sort complètement du
cadre légal
absolument
[Musique]
l'adoption doit être très encadré on a
déjà vu des phénomènes de cette nature
je repense au darfour à haïti où à
chaque fois c'est encore une fois sa
part toujours d'un bon sentiment c'est
de protéger ses enfants mais ça doit
être encadré la première des choses que
l'unicef demande c'est qu'on essaie de
chercher des membres de la famille
recommande d'abord d'essayer de
privilégier une adoption dans un cadre
familial ou en tout cas dans un cadre
très proche et lorsque ça n'est pas
possible évidemment ses enfants peut
être temporairement placés dans des
institutions mais qui sont encore une
fois très encadrée par les autorités et
ensuite éventuellement proposés à
l'adoption mais ça n'est vraiment pas la
première
quelques semaines après le début de
cette guerre ou encore une fois certains
de ses enfants ou encore leurs parents
en vie à l'intérieur de l'ukraine et on
doit temporairement les assurer leur
protection oui vous le disiez il ya ces
initiatives qui partent d'un bon
sentiment et puis il ya des intentions
moins nobles le trafic d'enfants ça
reste une réalité et ce phénomène est
accentué j'imagine leur en pleine guerre
alors évidemment les enfants sont des
proies faciles
alors on leur offre un abri ou là on
leur propose de l'aide
c'est vrai que nous on sait que
l'adoption est un danger tout ce qui est
pédophile i et prostitution où ces
jeunes enfants ukrainiens se sont
évidemment très exposé et c'est pour ça
que l'unicef et ses partenaires nous
sommes très présents postes frontières
justement pour les identifier les
prendre en charge le plus vite possible
avant qu'il sépare fils si je puis dire
comme ça dans le pays et que ce soit
beaucoup plus compliqué de deûle et de
les identifier et de d'assurer leur
protection parce que c'est notre mandat
de protéger ses enfants absolument je
lisais en avril sur le site de l'unicef
que vous aviez mis en place des centres
point bleu à la frontière donc des
espaces censé sécuriser les enfants en
tout cas les prendre en charge l'un ce
sont des espaces d'accueil à la
effectivement près des postes frontières
où un accueil n'est pas seulement les
enfants un accueil
réfugiés notamment les femmes et
accompagnées d'enfants et ça nous permet
de leur offrir un premier refus sur leur
route de leur exil qui est souvent bien
plus longue juste juste ces postes là
ces postes frontières avant qu'il soit
intégré dans dans des lieux d'accueil
plus moins temporaire si je puis dire et
on leur offre un abri on leur offre
un vieux d'hygiène de repos ils peuvent
aussi se reconnecter pour essayer de
retrouver des proches qui auraient fui
comme me mêler à d'autres à d'autres
endroits
donc c'est on en a une trentaine
opérationnel ou en train d'être
installée dans l'ensemble des pays
frontaliers et c'est un dispositif qu'on
avait déjà testé dans d'autres flux
migratoires et qui est très efficace et
surtout le plus important on prend en
charge les soins des traumas et
notamment en assure un soutien
psychologique aux enfants qui sont qui
sont traumatisés par cette suite brutale
en essayant de soi à travers des
activités ludo-éducatives soit une prise
en charge psychologique de réparer le
mieux possible leur trauma en tout cas
le plus vite possible parce qu'on sait
que plus est pris en charge tôt plus on
a des chances de se soigner et de
réparation processus de résilience on
sait quoi de la vie quotidienne des
enfants qui sont restés en ukraine est
ce que par exemple l'école fonctionne
encore alors l'école fonctionne encore
essentiellement à distance à fayyad vous
savez l'ukraine a aujourd'hui c'est il
ya des endroits totalement impraticable
bon vous l'avez vous l'avez vu à travers
les images et puis à des endroits un peu
plus sûres mais globalement l'école
fonctionne majoritairement à distance
nous avons
à l'intérieur de l'ukraine des équipes
continuaient d'assurer un soutien
éducatif et puis alex de l'ukraine j'ai
même une collaboratrice en france qui
depuis tours continue en tout cas
produire des fonds éducatif pour les
enfants ukrainiens donc c'est hyper
important que les enfants restent
scolarisés et gardent ce semblant
d'éducation même si ça n'est pas une
scolarité tout à fait normal ça leur
permet d'avoir
va dire un peu de normalité dans cette
vie d'enfant
g merci infiniment à l'avril d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je rappelle
vous êtes la directrice générale de
l'unicef france et que vous intervenez
donc pour ces millions de réfugiés qui
quittent l'ukraine notamment des enfants
merci à vous